all right before we dive into this
episode the minimalist want to help you
declutter your glowing screen so head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers to download any of our free
minimalist wallpapers including our love
people use things wallpaper for your
smartphone or computer enjoy
Chris and tallahassee has a question
hello guys this is Chris from Florida
the question is about writing i'm a
technical writer by trade as my day job
but i write fiction in my spare time
often i get an idea about a story that
i'm excited about and I'll start writing
but soon a newer sexier idea comes along
and I feel attempted to abandon the
first idea do you guys have some tips
for staying energized with an older idea
and finishing it before moving on to the
next thing so I think what you are
dealing with is is what Steven
Pressfield will call the resistance ya
sort of trademark resistance you're
starting a project you're doing the easy
parts and it's not that you're having
another idea then you can't stay focused
it's that ya beginning of the idea is
usually the easiest most fun part and so
you're just you're like water you're
just going downhill towards and then as
soon as it gets hard you're switching
directions so I would strongly suggest
reading the war of art and then it's
sort of the most important like creative
sort of manifesto of our times it's
helped me on all sorts of projects but I
would what I would do is the next time
you have an idea don't just sit down and
write the idea I would sit down and plan
out the idea so you're like okay here's
I would I would spend more time
researching and outlining and investing
in the idea so that your writing is not
is not dependent on enthusiasm or
excited inspiration is not what gets you
through the dip of a book it has to be a
purpose or a plan we're a very clear
sense of what like the outcome is even
if that's like I know what the last
sentence of this book is yeah there's a
fiction writer Harlan Coben he talks
about how he oh he knows what the book
begins and ends it's kind of like a map
if you know you're going to draw from
New Jersey to San Diego he knows the
beginning in the end and then he gets to
find the most secure distraught to sort
of get there and and that's that's the
adventure for him but he has a
destination in mind I will say this when
I think about writing and and maybe you
can you can shed some light on this Ryan
there are times where it does make sense
to bail on a project or it I think of
the second book I saw
writing fiction that was the thing that
did the the second novel I ever tried to
write it was a book called just past
central and it eventually died on the
vine possibly because the main character
dies in the first sentence of the book
and so like trying to figure out how I
like yeah yeah protracted it from there
was was really difficult and I spent the
better part of a year you know going
through different iterations and
eventually it didn't go anywhere and I
had to be willing to let go and it but
it wasn't because like oh I'm not
excited about this anymore it just it
wasn't a book I thought it was and it
ended up not being that I'm sure you've
had projects that you've worked on where
they didn't end up coming to fruition
yet another book recommendation Seth
Godin 'he's the dip because that's what
you you eventually you hit that point
you got to know do you keep going and
you're actually just digging deeper and
deeper or are you about to come out the
other side right for for me like one of
the things I do on my books is I break
them up in smaller pieces so like
stillness is the key actually I think
ego an obstacle almost exactly the same
way it's like three parts ten chapters
in each part so I'm not sitting there
going like what's this book you know
it's it's these small pieces of the book
so I'm sitting down and my job is to
write to you know a 2,000 word chapter
today or half of a 2,000 word chapter
today so doing that and then and then
but if you're doing in these small
pieces like originally you go as the
enemy was a book about humility and it
wasn't working as a book about humility
I couldn't I couldn't even find what the
chapters would be like so I was like
this is what I want I wrote it like I
had a good sense of the intro I had a
good sense of the arc or good since the
argument but it was like okay what are
the thirty stories that I'm filling this
book with and I found like three you
know and and so breaking up in smaller
pieces let me figure that out then it
was like oh actually this is a book
against ego and those stories filled up
like that right because those are some
of the most famous stories in history
right and so I think breaking your idea
down to pieces and and then looking at
these smaller things lets you get a
better sense of the whole than actually
looking at the whole thing one thing I
have to talk to writing students about
is also be care
because research can be very important
but it can also be enticing too and
prevent us from actually doing the work
and especially I imagine someone like
you you've you formed a date on between
writing and the research but there are
times where it's like well I'll just
I'll go off and read some more and and
not actually do the work but that that's
also where the outlining and since the
whole fits in I'm not just like walking
around with a net trying to catch things
you know that you hat you do want to
have a sense of what you're looking for
so it's like I'm trying to find what
those hear right not trying to find
things that could work generally
you